uh Mario Diaz from UNAM and he'll be
continuing talking about contraction of
Markov kernels and differential privacy
thanks a lot uh this is the first part
which was discussion second but now this
is the second part
no no no I mean it's like a Star Wars we
were telling him this over the coffee
you know you you first know what is the
end of the story and then you start
looking at the story also Lalita didn't
ask me to put more math but I did anyway
so hopefully it's gonna be terribly bad
so let me take over from uh
from the result right because we are
going to look at these pictures and try
to get some intuition on how to prove it
so we need to see a little bit of the
geometry of what's going on
so we have this uh projected dpsg deep
basically you have a starting point with
a certain distribution mu naught and
then you are going to iterate using that
rule right there
put in a more pictorical terms it looks
like this you have a point w t minus one
and then what you're gonna do is you
take a random batch of size B although
at some point we will see that the batch
is not very important I mean the
batching strategy is not very important
and then you do the update that you have
introduced which is uh pretty much
having grained the scent but it is going
to be clipped right I think here is an
important aspect of the psgd that you
have clipping
so what is going to happen you will have
a little bit of PSI BT here it's going
to put you somewhere right over there
here and then you are going to add the
standard gaussian noise you're going to
be somewhere else and then at the end
you project into this set W that for us
is going to be this beautiful Circle
so
what we proved is that you have
convergence right I think you have put
it very well uh this beautiful result by
Yang chokri and I'll show you learn
towards that the Privacy loss parameters
they converge so even though you can be
using the same data after a small
burning period you converge I mean the
Privacy loss is not the grain of course
this is in the Heat and state model if
you reveal the gradients along uh the
way that's going to be a different story
but if you keep them hidden you will you
will get something convergent it looks
pretty much like this it depends on this
uh probability P which is the batch size
over the sample size and this data that
he related to the strong data process
and inequality that we already saw so it
looks more or less like this I mean
we're going to work with Delta because
it's more natural to us but you can
always translate it to absolutely I mean
you can numerically at least convert
from Epsilon to deltas and the other way
around so
so the way we prove this as I have
already mentioned is using this a couple
non-linear DPI so if you remember the
first step is taking an update function
that depends on a random gradient
therefore there is a little bit of
Randomness in that step because it's
going from the uh random batch so we're
gonna model that it's in Markov kernel
so here what we are doing is we're
taking the apparage over all possible uh
batches of size B and here I'm abusing a
little bit of the notation I'm putting
functions but it doesn't mean the
average as a function it means the
average has the kernel because we can
always think of a function as a kernel
that takes a Delta w a mass of w and put
it in a mass at F of w so you can always
think of functions as kernels that's
what we are doing right there even
though it's we get something else Okay
so
as I have already pointed out the key
technical uh result or the the important
piece that comes somehow from the
information Theory realm is the
following if we have two neighboring
data sets X on x Prime and we let PSI
and PSI Prime be the update the steps
this once the red ones that I have here
then we are going to Define this uh K
which is going to be one step of the
psgd you see next and then we're gonna
Define K Prime which is going to be the
update of dpsgd using X Prime and we
have the following inequality the E
comma or hockey stick Divergence between
K mu and K Prime Nu is going to be less
or equal than one minus P Theta this is
the first part
with the hockey stick of new and new
and then we have plus P Theta now we
call it a couple nonlinear DPI I mean
non-linear is pretty obvious because you
have this part here the p uh Etc that it
is adding afterwards
and couple because typically when you
have data process and inequality you use
the same kernel here you don't have this
internal although they are coupled they
share the same Randomness what is the
randomness the batch the batch is the
common Randomness and the only thing
that is different is the X and the X
Prime and most of the time they are the
same because it is almost the same data
set except for when I
so
the way we're gonna prove it is in three
steps uh should have a little bit
mention some of them uh the first part
is the bachelor strategy it turns out
that the batching strategy is not very
important because you can use what we
call the join complexity of the F
Divergence in this case is focus stick
Divergence but it holds for any
Divergence
then we are gonna use the strong leader
processing inequality that you have
mentioned and and for here it's very
important that we have projection if you
don't have projection then everything
breaks and this is going to come up
later in the talk
and then we will use this neighboring
data sets using a coupling argument
right as I mentioned it the randomness
is shared by this VT
and the only thing that is different is
one data data point so we are going to
exploit that at the very end
so well this is an information uh
theoretic uh Workshop no what is that uh
worship on information theoretic methods
so we'll repeat the method even though
La Liga didn't ask me to do it but I'm
going to do it anyway
so
yeah yeah if it is too much stop me and
I'm gonna go through slowly and
hopefully it's gonna be
it's very easy enough so anyway so we
have the definition of side you remember
what it was this linear combination of
the kernels that give you one update for
one kernel so we can pretty much plug it
to the pi which is the projection K
gaussian kernel same notation I should
have and then compose with the updates
for this batches right so it pretty much
is transparent you just plug it here and
that's it then we remember that our
favorite
measuring distance between probability
distributions we just have divergences
they are going to converts all of them
so we can use it for egamma Divergence
in particular what we know is that the
e-commer Divergence between uh the
convex combination and the same
combination is going to be the circle
than the convex combination which is
corresponding to that so here what it
means is that pretty much we can take
the batch and strategy out and in fact
uh we are just talking about uh sampling
without replacement which means taking
uh batches of size B without replacement
but pretty much you can put anything
which is kind of independent because it
goes out I mean at some point you need
to compute the probability of using the
bad guy you know the different guy but
that's uh but that's about it so we are
going to take out the batching strategy
here
and then we are going to use uh data
process and inequality to take this
projection out just with coefficient one
because I mean typically projections
there's nothing you can do with them I
mean the contraction coefficient is one
therefore uh there is no strong data
process inequality or anything you just
pick it up
they're gonna come back again but that's
going to be later so the model of this
is that we don't need uh to worry much
about the batching strategy because we
have complexity of divergences and in
fact this was uh an important part of
the proof by year and shokri
but they use the explaining shaded rainy
Divergence which is uh almost enough
Divergence so this is what's already
known somehow we are borrowing but they
used in a different language and setting
so anyway
um then the second part is what you have
mentioned here we call it as constrained
it doesn't matter what it is what it
says what it means is that you have
measures that takes value in a certain
set
what we call S then the calcium kernel
the typical adding juice calcium kernel
so it causes noise with barium Sigma is
going to have this contraction
coefficient which is the size of the set
the diameter of s over Sigma that's it
and if you remember this Theta Epsilon
was some Q function which is the error
for the calcium distribution and so on
but that's not very important so what we
are going to do here is for dpsd the way
to compute this is we need to understand
what happens after you apply the optic
function right it is not just W you need
to apply the object function so what we
prove is the following simple Lemma and
actually it's very easy to see it you
have your set W the worst that could
happen is that you start at a post data
points you have W1 in one extreme w20
dealer extreme
then the gradient might want to push you
even further away but because it is
clipped and we have the Stepside Theta
well you're not going to go very far
probably you're going to only get two e
to the C and that's it if you are lucky
if you if you are not maybe you go even
back
so at the end what you end up is with a
region which is the diameter of
probability that's where that magical
number came because it's taking some
control of that and therefore
if you remember in this last slide we
had this uh hockey stick Divergence
between the calcium kernel applied to
side B mu and the same thing applied to
psi Prime U so we can just put the
contraction coefficient here and that's
it that step is uh it's done
so
Somehow Here the model of the story and
again this is not new story we did this
uh with Flavio a couple of years ago and
also it's been something that people
have been using also in the Reddit uh
differential privacy setting is that if
you have boundedness of certain kind and
then you apply the gaussian kernel you
tend to make distributions closer and in
information Theory we call that the
strong data process in the quality so
that's very familiar to us
now the last step in this direction is
the coupling argument
so up to now we are pretty much here if
you remember we had this uh
original holistic Divergence we said
well we're gonna take the batching out
because uh during Quebec City and then
we had this Theta Factor because of the
stronger data plus and inequality and we
are left with this part here there's a
steel Randomness because well not
Randomness because now it's fixed but
there's still the patch that we need to
take care of
so the way we are going to do it is a
very uh a simple way is that if they are
equal you know if PSI B is equal to psi
Prime B which means you are not using
the different data point in X and X
Prime
then we are going to bound it using data
processing inequality the regular
version that we teach in information
Theory
so it's going to be less or equal than e
gamma mu and mu
but if they are different that happens
when you take the data point which is
different we are going to put a one okay
I'm going to come back to that one but
in a minute
what we can conclude from this is you
estimate what is the probability of not
using
the different guy
this probability one minus p and what is
the probability of using
the different guy the probability SP
that's why you get the B Over N it's
just a simple computation and that's why
I said that the batching strategies
doesn't matter as long as you can
compute what's the probability of having
the bad guy
in the batch that's enough
[Music]
now up to this point the analysis seems
kind of
right or maybe not tight but reasonable
the only part that well at least in my
opinion I mean maybe I can get some
comments on on
what do you think about the timings of
this but this one looks very lazy right
I mean at least I was a little bit
annoyed when we found this proof because
I said well probably here we are wasting
a lot I'm not very convinced
but
after thinking it a little bit more uh
it seems that without complexity it's
very hard to improve it
now um
probably I'm not going to explain it
because it takes a little bit of
time but if you grab a piece of paper
and a cup of coffee probably you can
convince yourself that in the non-convex
case it's very hard to beat it because
one lost function can push the measure
mu that we originally have further in
One Direction and then the other measure
for the other loss function is going to
be pushed forward the other way around
so if you want to do it in a classical
strong data process in an equality way
you're gonna do it because you will end
up with larger coefficients than just
one so it doesn't make a lot of sense to
try something else there but I don't
know maybe I'm wrong because also there
is no limit on how much you can push but
anyway
I I put that that cup of coffee because
I said you can grab a piece of paper and
a cup of coffee and they're usually very
famous uh coffee shop near the street
but I get my breakfast every day it's
called Uh Cafe Estrada which is where uh
Barry Mason and Ken rivet this cause one
of the important pieces of fair mats uh
last year improved so I don't know it's
it's kind of a
characteristic place for uh nerds like
like us right so anyway that's a great
place to grab a cup of coffee
how much time do I have I started
pipe right
not everything okay yeah that's great
so
we already talked about the uh the
projected version right we have the PHD
which is projected but some might say
well maybe projection is not very
realistic
maybe you can do uh something else well
this is what we tried
uh there's gonna be a similar setting
I'm gonna put a tilde to the note that
is regularized right because we have the
projected one which which was just the
regular W so to do not uh interfere with
the notation I'm gonna put a tilde means
that it is regularized
and the strategy is pretty much the same
I mean you start with a point w t minus
one then you take a random batch
as always it doesn't matter much and
then the update function has two pieces
because it's going to be regularized
we are going to have a minus Lambda here
which typically comes from
regularization by the way that here the
regularization goes outside the clipping
but at least uh that's the way uh yeah
and shock we discussed for some examples
so it's the same thing that we are going
to use here
so
it looks pretty much like this first you
have a little bit of regularization that
it is pushing you towards the origin
and then you have the updated step which
is the regular clipping divided by the
number of the size of the batch times it
and then we add a little bit of noise
and we end up in a place like here right
now
there's no projection
and we said that in order to have the
strong data process and inequality we
need projection because otherwise the
contraction coefficient becomes one and
actually you can recompile the whole
thing without projection but you get a
very bad number and and it converges to
something bigger than one and Delta is
always less than one so there is no
point in doing that and kind of makes
sense because if you don't have any
restriction how do you expect to use any
of that noise to provide privacy
here
the key idea to handle this is that
if you notice here I put that zero but
it doesn't matter I mean you can put a
small neighborhood of zero it's the same
at the end
and you have bounded the steps this is
Step function sorry this update function
is bounded by eat the thief and gaussian
noise it is not bounded but for the most
part it is right I mean the probability
of a constant random variable between
minus 12 and 12 is like one I mean it's
practically one
so
it turns out that if you think about it
for some time you realize that
there is like this typicality idea right
going on for the most part you're gonna
be in the set which we are going to call
the ball of radius RT minus one
and because the gradient or or this uh
updated steps are gonna push you at most
ETA C and the gaussian noise is going to
push you some constant Factor at most
you cannot be very far right so it's
going to increase a little bit
how much well it has e plus some
constant
and if you continue eventually you reach
some sort of effective equilibrium why
because even if the gradient is trying
to push you away from zero
and also uh
the noise let's assume the gaussian
noise is not very good to you that day
and it's trying to push you outside
nonetheless you have this uh
regularization part which is pushing you
towards the center again so at some
point you reach some sort of equilibrium
and you don't go very far and that's
what we call our Infinity here
so the idea is going to define a new
process that we are going to call the
projected copy study that copy and then
pass the guarantees through the
regularized version
so the way to do it is very
straightforward you do predictions we
have exactly the same thing but we have
an extra projection here which is going
to be projected to some disks well some
balls a certain radius RT now the radius
we can play with it yes so why is it
that the noise cannot proceed to
Infinity because you keep adding well it
can yeah no that's a great Point
actually it can push you to Infinity but
the probability is very small
the probability is very small right
because I mean you have regularization
so in order to stay like I don't know
beyond one million in Norm you need to
be very unlucky that the noise is
pushing you super hard towards uh
infinity
because look this is growing right
you're talking so the regularization is
always pushing you hard towards the
origin I mean a spark that you get the
stronger you can push back
so you get some sort of like Deliverance
of that it's actually what we'll mention
a part of that in the next slide
yeah but what is going to happen is that
then this Infinity
region is going to get larger which
makes sense right I mean when you make
Lambda equal to zero nothing is grabbing
you so words Theory and therefore the
radius just gets increasing pretty good
again
because that's
kind of intuitive okay so we have
projection how the projection
or else it's kind of neutral right the
idea is that you don't use it much
right because otherwise this process
will be different I mean remember the
KDs to study this process and then pass
the guarantee to the other one
if you use the projection a lot
then they are going to be very different
and whatever you say for this is going
to be relevant for the other piece so
what we have to do is make the radius
large enough so that we don't use the
projection a lot a lot
but you want to make it smaller because
you will get a very current a better
guarantee so we're going to play a
little bit with it
I'm going to show you how in the next
slide so what we are going to prove is
the following it looks very ugly
let me read it carefully
with you
so we have the regularized process right
so we have training with X that we will
call wtild.t and training with X Prime
which we call it w tilde Prime okay same
notation as before
as I have already mentioned
the financial privacy is measuring
holistic convergence right we put e to
the Epsilon sorry e Epsilon and we want
to understand the distance in income and
Divergence between those two variables
that's what we want now
because
in the projected copy we have projection
we can actually apply what I showed you
in the first half right you can have a
strong data processing inequality you
take the batching out you do everything
except that now you have some numbers D
that depend on the radius because before
it was fixed but nothing changes and
actually this looks a lot like what we
had before if you put our equal to
whatever number then this is a geometric
series and everything collapses right
so this is the part
this is what we
want
by taking the projections now we can
understand the gamma Divergence between
WT which is a projected copy train on X
and WT Prime which is a projected copy
trend on X Prime exactly as we did in
the first half nothing changed
now but that's not what we want we want
this part
so the way to proceed
is well maybe we can understand how far
these two guys are
how far
the projected copy and the original copy
are well it turns out that you can
compute the total variation distance
between those two variables and it is
this Factor right here
now the proof is a little bit of
Tranquility because why not
and I mean for free you can get the
other one because it is just changing X
for X Prime that's in material
and finally you need to put everything
together
now
a little bit more triangle inequality
but now it's for the hockey stick
Divergence there is a very nice strangle
in the quality for hockey stick
Divergence that at least I got it from
Leo call from produce paper I don't know
if it was known before but pretty much
it tells you that you can do a usual
triangle inequality with the hook signal
Gardens but there's a little bit of a
price to pay
if you apply travel inequality the usual
way you should get one plus one here
because you are applying it twice but in
that inequality you need to pay a little
bit of the Gammas for e to the Epsilon
in this case so that's why you get the
one plus C to the Epsilon here
now uh Matthew block uh was laughing a
little bit while smiling I would say
smiling because I always tell this this
job I don't know if you heard that um
a famous Professor at MIT is doing
mathematics and philosophy he said that
every mathematician has only few tricks
right and the first time we met I was
telling him that there is people with
this beautiful ideas in Duality between
abstract spaces that's their trick some
other people have symmetries which is
something very impressive I mean when it
works it works beautifully I only have
struggles in the quality so I gotta do
what I gotta do man
I'm talking about doing what you've got
to do but we could put proof with this
was probably the
top geometer of
current mathematics and I think there's
an article if I'm saying yeah I mean the
things that he can do with triangle
inequality
so don't don't sell yourself short okay
okay yeah no no no yeah I'm gonna take a
look I'm gonna take a look
yeah because
anyway what we could do with Tranquility
is a problem
so we could prove that
after heat ratios this regularized the
PHD with this Delta which is the Delta
that I showed in the previous slide now
something that I didn't tell you is that
we can play a little bit with the Arts I
mean we have another Factor here Kappa
because uh probably you didn't realize I
was trying to be fast so to sneak it in
there is a constant Kappa and this works
for any Kappa so you can play with that
Kappa a little bit
it's due to the numerical experiments
what you find out is that if you
optimize the scapout you'll get
something of this sort for regular cpsgd
is pretty much the same parameters that
you have had in other words like this is
essentially the same thing and actually
if you compare them there a little bit
better which makes sense because you are
taking a small radius first and
eventually they converge to something
and the other one you have a big radius
from the start here is increasing a
little by little so you get something
way better
now she have said that we don't have
convergence because we don't in the
sense of uh proven it or
um in an abstract manner I mean
numerically it seems to converge I mean
if you even go through we'll stay the
same but since you have the Kappa and
you need to move it for each iteration
it's a little bit tricky so hopefully at
some point we will get it I don't know
if it's going to work because I only
have to turn on the quality right so but
if it works will we have convergence
even for the regular RC psgd if not it's
just numeric but it is good numbers I
mean probably it's not you know as good
as we would like to have that I think
the original numbers
yeah yeah right but I mean
and that's kind of the trick and also
it's very sensitive I mean you're gonna
study this you've seen a central limit
here or large aviations and you realize
that you don't have to move unlocked
right you are pretty much a
square root of d d is the dimensional
data and you have to move a little bit
in that region so it's kind of tricky
because numbers start to grow also this
has to be very small sorry very close to
one or two small
yeah which makes sense right because we
have a calcium nodes which is moving and
we want to keep it in a boundary world
that's pretty much the camera yeah
thanks for pointing that out that Kappa
basically is telling us where we are
chopping them you know like but we want
to chop that
I mean we have some ideas on where to
take uh the Kappa which is like square
root of B plus minus something but it's
very hard to manipulate because it
starts rolling so turn on
but anyway the point is if we get
something converted
uh just finish a final remarks
so we started in the hidden State
setting because well if you reveal
intermediate steps without some other
business but In the Heat of the Hidden
estate setting we started both uh
projected a regularized PhD
and we show that the Privacy loss or the
differential privacy parameters they
converge in the number of iterations so
that means that after the small burning
period you can actually keep training
and you want you want software of
privacy through correlation now a key
part of this was not using complexity
assumptions and it is not just because
we could but because we needed to even
if you have complex losses once you clip
them they are not convex
so we had to find a way out
and the way was
um
information Theory so
we use this a couple non-linear data
processing inequality
and something that that perhaps is more
important that the actual numbers that
we got is that it seems like this
convergence of the differential privacy
parameters is going to be kind of
universal right I mean you don't need
complexity you don't need smoothness
I mean you need to chop it off at some
point in some way but generally because
exactly to have this movement so it
convex or whatever so hopefully this is
going to be a little bit helpful in
um trying to extend this and showing
that more iterative algorithms they
actually compare to the other day I was
reading some paper from the anodes of
statistics and they have iterative
processes for L1 penalized linear
regressions and it's also iterative
right and they were having this analysis
that scale with key well in those cases
probably some adaptation or maybe
inspiration from these ideas would be
helpful so anyway I'm gonna stop here I
guess great thank you
[Applause]
plenty of times for questions I actually
want to start with the question so
um
uh how this so if you get your bow and
then compare it in the convex setting
with the bounce back from Strawberry and
others like how do they compare
uh we haven't done that that's what we
are going to do in the next couple of
weeks
I have a related question so what was
shocker using the regularized before
because they were it was was that a way
to still work it out with the can I get
a strong complexity okay yeah yeah I
mean you can use regularization because
some complexity if you have comebacks
you have losses then you have
recovery function you have sometimes
don't come back so that was more or less
this period I mean here is to keep it
under control but I mean it is similar
you know going back to India's question
I mean
you have a strict guarantee that you
will never be unbounded so that's a drag
I mean if that could be very small
okay that the term you're bounding the
chi-squam
Hillary could be very large well we want
to close the one but it could be a small
I mean it could be the bad but I mean
you can optimize I I mean that's why we
don't claim that we we know convergence
to reduce because we need to play a
little bit with Kappa
we need to work a little bit more on
that but I mean it seems it's going to
converge or at least numerically I mean
I can see which was small signals right
for any Sigma right
you can always appeal to large
deviations and you see that you should
kind of converge and I mean it's very
subtle but
yeah I mean probably in a couple of
weeks
next so when you when you mention
non-linear as bpis
um
there was there was a couple of papers
from from Yuri polianski did with the
supply video on on the non-linear as
dpis for various I mean I think that
they had they're this for additive noise
channels but uh it's still a stronger
methodology baby so look at this uh what
they call the data processing because
they call it the the brutian curve of
the channel
right if you look at the inputs uh
Divergence the variation or jail or
whatever and then you compare it against
output diversions you don't necessarily
look for linear scale
is this something that that could have
uh also been related to this work or or
uh is there a difference despite just
the appearance of non-linear
in the name
I mean the short answer is properly I
mean I cannot tell for a certain but but
that's that that comes to mind right I
mean replacing all this strong data
processing inequality stuff with
something a little bit more
sophisticated which by the way that I
mean that family of papers are one of my
favorite one here we couldn't use it
well not yet
because it's a little bit tricky to set
it off I mean yeah you know yeah that's
right that's right so so in principle it
could but for me to find I mean to to do
the fine tuning and adapt it but but
definitely I mean that's going to be the
next thing right but I mean here somehow
the the key point
I think is showing the universality of
the behavior and then we are going to
set up in a chain
which by the way between us
probably somebody in the future if
anyone gets into this but I mean this
came out after after a couple of
failures trying to use a non-linear dpis
in in some other settings so so so
that's gonna be the next stop yeah
definitely you know we have time for one
more question
um so I want
it to happen now you have to take my
question
um
those are from theoretical analysis but
if you were to actually validate uh like
privacy guarantee on the trained models
how would you go about that so you mean
a lot like
Chicken in yeah
yeah because I mean here here is
yeah I can somehow
our main world was to be established
controlling another case it's different
assumptions that steal this emergency
yeah how to audit that
actually that's a great lead-in for the
next stock
um
foreign